good morning everyone and welcome to
division three work session on what is
Senate Bill 239 the title is an act
relative to the use of harm reduction
services to treat alcohol and other
substance misuse
representative Jess Edwards the chair of
this division is unexpectedly able to be
here today however I will chair this
work session and information session my
name is representative Maureen Mooney
from the town of Merrimack Vice chair of
this division
so we have with us today members of
division three as well as those who have
worked as I understand it very
thoroughly on House Bill 239 and the
hope today is to maybe have a maximum of
a 90-minute or so discussion and
information sharing related to the bill
and then we'll pick it up again in
September for some decisions to be made
so with that I understand with us today
is Senator Waters as well as
representative Nagel representative
Shapiro
former representative Solway former
representative I'm sorry
Hannon
today who have worked extensively on
this bill
and so with that why don't we start by
walking through it if the committee
members are amenable to that and either
Senator Waters or representative Nagel I
think could probably take that on if
you're amenable to starting at that
point thank you well thanks so much
representative Mooney and uh nice to see
all the fellow colleagues and we're
almost done aren't we you know Thursday
and I tell you what a session it's been
but um it's nice to have a chance to to
revisit this before we take our summer
break and I I'm sorry uh the
representative Edwards is not here and
wish him uh well and we had had a zoom
webinar or conference or call together a
few days ago to go over a lot of the
issues that emerged during the finance
three uh hearing on the bill and the
questions as an excellent session
um with some of the harm reduction
Coalition folks and um from that I think
we've developed some approaches and some
some thoughts and also
um I believe that representative Edwards
and I will visit one of the syringe
exchange sites in Manchester together so
have a have a chance to look a little
bit more about what we're talking about
when we talk about harm reduction and I
um would like to say that the folks
would be happy for any other
representative who wants to you know
just go out in the field and see how how
harm reduction actually works you'd be
more than welcome and that can be set up
and then um very timely really kind of
hot off the press uh the project that
Carrie Nolte and others have been doing
to try to provide some educational
materials and and guide particularly for
policy makers and uh you have before you
drafted that report which they were
willing to share a little a little early
um and uh they uh really some are here
today but they're just done
extraordinary working trying to lay out
uh information on this topic and I think
particularly for finance three you know
you're not HHS and uh you know how it is
on legislators such as myself who I've
done a Governor's commission and I've
been involved with these things for for
decades and you know how we all focus
and it's like oh yeah maybe other people
in the world don't understand what I'm
talking what we're talking about and so
I I hope you will find that information
helpful and um so Madam Vice chair
without kind of going into too much
detail because I've been before you
before let me just very briefly go over
the the sections of the bill and perhaps
towards the end it would be better if
representative Nagel came forward
because he worked on a definitional
materials at the at the end um and then
I really would just like to see what
kind of questions that you may have
um to set up whatever kind of work will
continue in September so thank you I
will do that if that's okay Senator
would you like the questions as you
speak or at the end anything you want to
do anytime at all great for anyone here
at the table thank you
so I will kind of Go part by part
um and let me just by way of background
say that I am on the governor's
commission and Alcohol and Other Drugs
worked with Senator Forester in
particular about a decade ago in
revising that commission and its Mission
and um over the last uh two years the
commission has developed a new strategic
plan and you can find that online at on
the HHS website for the commission and
really a very thorough process and
see what the evolving area was and you
know the the governor set up the
doorways program Federal money has come
in a lot has gone on and the Strategic
plan reflected that and in particular it
identified a new task force area
on harm reduction
and recognizing that that was becoming a
kind of a catch-all term for the things
that you try to do to prevent disease uh
and to deal with the health impacts of
folks who have substance misuse disorder
this can you know the prevention here on
harm reduction you know let's continue
to reduce HIV infection
let's see if we can you know try to
reduce hep C
um let's see if we can try to reduce
infections that you know kind of mean
heart heart valve Replacements
um all the other kinds of of health
effects wound treatment
um now a lot of this has circled around
um needle exchange which uh working with
Senator gray and representative Hanner
who got that one of the people got that
started a number of years ago that's
what you know a 10 cent syringe needle
can mean you're not spending a half
million dollars on a heart valve
replacement or on HIV treatment so
um harm reduction
um is is a wide area
um but I thought that it was essential
since that's what the commission is
taking on that harm reduction as a
phrase ought to be in the governing
language for the commission
HHS also wanted us in this first part to
use the term substance misuse rather
than substance abuse that's their kind
of where they are in terms of the
language that's used so that's why you
see that here too
um related to the commission as well
you'll see I think very importantly that
we're adding
um the president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police I think
that's an important seat to add to the
commission so that we can better
coordinate as you'll see later on in the
bill on harm reduction and syringe
exchange services with
um local public safety officials because
that's that coordination has been an
issue so that's the first part
um of it and you'll just see a few pages
really of
throwing in the term harm reduction and
um misuse prevention
and uh
then um
if you'll go to uh page three
um
you'll see the opioid abatement advisory
commission and this section of the bill
tries to bring together
the work of the opioid abatement
advisory commission and the governor's
Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drugs that Commission
on the opioid abatement was set up you
know rather quickly when we got the
settlement funds and and I think wisely
the governor decided that there ought to
be a separate commission that dealt with
those funds it's kind of like what we do
with the water settlement and the other
other ones it's a good it's a good way
to go but what was left undone at that
time uh was the coordination with the
governor's Commission on alcohol their
drugs which provides the advice on how
we spend a lot of federal funding on the
same area so there ought to be
coordination there I worked with Senator
Rosenwald who's on the commission and
others on the commission to say here's
the kind of language and it was in
Senate Bill 32 it's in here years as
well for do to do that and then at the
bottom of page three something else that
I I think is very important about the
bill is the doorways program now we
don't name it that because that's just a
kind of Grant terminology but you'll see
substance use disorder access points
established
what I what I thought we needed to do
legislatively is that the governor
established the doorways program by
order because we got Federal grant
funding
the state
opioid response Project funding many
many millions of dollars going out to
the states New Hampshire got enhanced
funding because we were in a top ten for
overdose deaths and uh the governor
um put forward a plan to establish these
doorways which are access points for all
kinds of
programs and services somebody can come
in and get immediately referred to the
emergency room if that's what that's
what they're looking for they can also
be put in touch with um
you know all kinds of services
uh related
to recovery and and other things and
health care and other things as well and
I think that the doors program has
proven the wisdom of the governor's
decision to do it this way there are
associated with the hospitals they are
separate entities
um that have really served an awfully
important role uh and I thought that you
know it seemed to me very important
having approved itself that we ought to
have it in statute and I think also too
this kind of sets us in a good place
to have state authority over what this
does you know Federal grant funded but
we need to make sure we're doing it in a
New Hampshire way and having it in
statute is important there are going to
be considerations about the stability
and con
continuity of this Sor the federal
funding if we have this in statute we
will be able to
address if there are any needs and the
state needs to consider how do we run
this program in conjunction with with
Federal funding whether I think this is
an important move for uh us to have have
done that
the next part of the bill on page four
gets a little more into the heart of the
matters that were of concern uh in this
division
um in in approaching well okay what do
we mean by harm reduction and what are
we doing you know what does that term
comprehend and what kind of activities
and so on
um the bill
focuses on the syringe service programs
and it tries to do
um certain things you'll see
uh there on blind seven
um I mentioned earlier the chiefs of
police Manchester in particular has had
great concerns about coordination
um with harm reduction activity and
syringe Services Program so after a
great deal of work with the chiefs of
police and uh with members of house in
the Senate and others came up with this
section here to say that there would be
coordinating collaboration and I think
that will set a much better foundation
with law enforcement and other folks if
we have certain service programs do that
in that consultation
um and then um in starting online uh 17
with uh section 13.
um syringe service programs and uh
one thing here is you'll see that the
bill crosses out that sentence about
General funds having I think
representative Hannah can certainly
speak to the this and this is an
important part of the work that was done
with Senator gray to finally get the
syringe service program set up to have
some assurance that state funds would
would not be used for it
um made sense politically at the time I
think that the program has proved such a
value that having a Prohibition here
maybe isn't really functional or
appropriate anymore if you talk to the
folks who run these programs they say
that they really scramble to sustain
funding federal grants
the good graces of the hospitals which
accept the needles that they receive
and will put them in our Disposal system
which is expensive rather than having
that be a charge to the programs I mean
a lot of informal relationships cobbled
together to make these work a lot of
volunteer efforts and so on
um right now that that that's the system
but they're worried about it how do we
sustain the funding because this is the
front lines in in preventing a serious
illness death and and so forth so that's
why that's stricken
um it occurred to me in conversation
with representative Edwards and others
that if that creates uh anxiety to take
it out
um then maybe don't take it out
because frankly if the legislature
decides that it would want to put some
money into these programs it at that
point could repeal this you know and
changes anyway so I I thought why not do
it now but if that's an issue for the
then that's that's why that's there very
good representative Shapiro for a
question so so if we leave that in and
do away with the prohibition on General
funds
um funding is that in effect saying that
we are going to fund them with General
funds it gets us back thanks for the
question it gets us back to being silent
on the question that's what I thought
right and um you know you're you know
well you're you're division three right
that if any money is going to be put in
the budget the next budget this this uh
any any reminds me of putting the next
budget um I suppose there's a situation
where somebody now could come to join
physical and say we you know we really
need some funding for for X we've got
some in some general you know in some of
our other funding in HHS or whatever I
don't anticipate that but it would make
it would get us back to soccer it would
take other action for it actually for
the funds to come from the general funds
um but you know if that CR if that if
that in itself is an issue right now
legislatures can do what they want
representative Weber for a question
thank you
um
it's partly a question and partly a
statement if that's acceptable
um
as I read the language that
you are proposing to strike through it
it says the use of state general funds
shall be prohibited unless otherwise
appropriated by the general court so am
I not correct in Reading what is in
existence now as saying G General Court
any time you want to through the budget
process or in another appropriation
appropriate money for this program it's
fine all that I read that as prohibiting
is the use of funds that were
appropriated for some other purpose and
unspent being lateral to this program am
I correct about that thank you and I
think so and uh
you know and one could argue that maybe
it would make sense to strike it that's
why I put I did this because that
circumstance might come up in between
budgets and joint physical would then
um you know have that that opportunity
because if it be you know if it looks
like a needle exchange program is going
to shut down or or something
um oh my gosh you know we wouldn't want
that
um and it's sometimes it's easier than
that you know if it is it's silent so
that there's that flexibility but as I
said
you know if that's something that's of
if striking has a concern fine you know
then I think that that makes the
committee more comfortable with that
section of the bill there because really
the heart of this is um the way that
I've handled starting in section 14. the
issue about paraphernalia
um there are a number of bills about
this
we have passed a very narrow bill on
fentanyl test strips that says that they
can be used but it's a larger issue
um because there's lots of supplies
which might be construed as
paraphernalia
the approach that I took in the bill
was not to say that possession of those
is legal I I think that that is
something that may be a step too far
right now for law enforcement and I I
understand that
what I didn't want to see is a situation
where the folks who are licensed are an
organizations licensed by HHS to go out
and deliver harm reduction supplies
might be subject to arrest
I I just think we can't ask people who
are are there to do that so what it
tries to do is to set up
um drug checking and then also you look
on to
page five
um drug checking equipment drug supplies
eligible activities and so on
um all of this looks a whole lot like
harm reduction activities
um and so this is the approach the bill
takes I do think that this will help
save lives
I think it'll offer clarity
and I also think that it's very
significant that this is a version and
approach that
um I won't and I won't you know Beth is
here but after a lot of work with the
Chiefs and uh and other law enforcement
folks that this this seemed comfortable
they seemed okay with this approach to
it so that's why that's why it looks
this way
okay thank you Senator
um a couple of thoughts here one of
which is for example a glossary type
section I think may put some members
more at ease and you you have one more
or less at the end of page four but
other terms such as access points or
things of that nature that may need more
fleshing out
would you be opposed to that and can you
see the
the uh the concern there
uh that that would make some sense I I
think you know access point I I think of
the doorways I think of um the uh harm
reduction services that are being
offered and it's a variety of them uh
you know SOS recovery does it one way
the folks in Nashua do it another way
the folks in Manchester do it another
way so
um I just I think the definition would
need to uh in a sense take a snapshot of
what we're doing now
okay so yes thank you understood and
another thought here uh on page five
under drug supplies a whole list of
items here
um
yet on the page before it only addresses
syringes
so in the instance of pipes or
paraphernalia things of that nature is
that um
being exchanged now or is that
definition section on page five
just all-inclusive
uh what I'm specifically referring to is
page five lines nine through eleven
right
um thank you for the question now
you'll see what this what this does is
refers
um back more particularly to on to lines
32.
um about this
uh excuse me a little bit a little bit
further up
um
excuse me line 26.
that
this notwithstanding of the law of the
contrary that is kind of referencing the
paraphernalia laws okay so what it's
saying that okay paraphernalia laws
sometimes are explicit sometimes they're
not so much vocal no statutes about what
is considered paraphernalia so the
attempt here is to clarify for the
practitioners practitioners of the
exchange programs and for law
enforcement here's the list
and um the drug supplies
um these are things that are being
distributed
and there some of them could be in a
kind of a gray area
each one is being distributed because of
demonstrable Public Health need
that that you know the wounds
um
clean straws I mean there's some things
I mean I I know there's discomfort about
this but these are some of the ways that
the drugs are consumed and if they're
not clean
it's a public health problem for HIV for
hep C you name it so that's these are
the things that you will find in the
at this at the syringe exchange sites
um you know programs so that that's why
um
that's why and then on the drug checking
things too you don't want somebody who's
transporting
uh some Supply or some syringe or
whatever for checking to be then caught
for possession
so that's why you have
um that section in in there
so uh I think that it's one of those
ones where if you read the document that
was provided today you'll get a little
clearer sense of just how these harm
reduction supplies are used what what
the reason for them are and um I'm the
bill as I said want is taking the
approach not to say that it's legal for
anybody who has anything to possess them
that's good that's it's kind of that's
in a law enforcement decision for the
individual
but for the service provider
I don't think they should be subject to
arrest for paraphernalia law violations
because they are Distributing these harm
reduction supplies so that's that's why
the bill takes the shape it does
but thank you for that because to see
you know pipes and snorting straws pipe
covers in the same list as you know
water saline and a tourniquet it raises
some thoughts yeah representative
Shapiro please for question
thank you I'd like to comment or ask
about the overlap between House Bill 287
which I believe was concurred
um with I don't know that it's been
signed by the governor or not but that
refers to
um drug paraphernalia and it includes
xylazine as well as fentanyl with
um as one of the permitted drug checking
um yeah
tools that are that that would not be
included would not be
subject people to penalties so I'm
wondering if that should
if that's taking care of the situation
or if xylazine should be listed in these
um drug testing in in 239 along with
fentanyl strips thanks for the thank you
for the question and um
you know the Senate decided to do some
things about xylodine we've had some
thorough presentations about it on the
governor's commission
um
the wound issue
um let alone the fact that Narcan
doesn't work on it
um it's it's it's terrible and gonna be
a complicated issue
um
two things about this bill
right now I do not believe there are any
commercially available xylodine tests
maybe folks I think they're being
developed but I'm not sure that they're
there yet so but the Senate was
concerned about being ready for that
um I did ask
some research to be done on
if there are issues of overlap with the
bill the federal test stripped and the
xylodine bill and that that one and it
seems that
the sections of law and the approach
takes particular different so I think
they're complementary
um but I think there could be some
further look
at as whether any of this actually needs
to change my feeling is that it doesn't
but that's something that you know by
the Fall may become clearer
thank you
representative Weber for a question
thank you madam chair uh my question is
kind of the coming at the same thing
issue that I think
Madam chair was coming at from a
different direction when I look at the
list of drug supplies
I Wonder Part of Me wonders why include
cotton filters alcohol wipes water
saline and tourniquets and probably the
disposal containers as well in wound
care items because those are all none of
those are are illegal items they're
items that are used commonly in all
kinds of different practices is the
purpose for including those in this list
simply one that means that they would
then be eligible for funding if if
funding were available or
is would there be
some use to recognizing that some of
these things are not like the others and
some of them are already perfectly legal
to have and to use for whatever purpose
thanks for the question and um you know
I I'm not an attorney and it might be
the Chiefs the police can give you some
clarity on this but you know a cotton
ball
or a tourniquet
um in one circumstance maybe just seen
as some medical supply in those
circumstances it might be seen as
paraphernalia
and that's that's that's the clarity
that I wanted that for these folks who
have have this the the boxes of these
materials in their van or wherever and
they're out doing a new exchange
programs and if people say I need some
of that or need some of that this that
the folks running the programs might
would not be subject to any ambiguity
over whether or not they are
Distributing illegal paraphernalia with
these things so the list is it's kind of
comprehensive but you know this is
recognizing
um
those those those items
so um Madam chair you know I've already
I'm already rambled on but let me just
be I'll try to be a little briefer and
then maybe um representative Nagel could
actually talk more about the uh
definitions issue
so another thing here uh you know and
again worked for a number of years on
this kind of issues of um training so
bottom of page five
um continuing medical education
requirement uh heard from a lot of
of uh medical personnel that the the
concerns about the so-called X waiver
which has since been repealed but that
very much limited how many patients you
could treat under what circumstances and
what kind of Licensing you needed to do
medically assisted treatment for
substance misuse
and so originally the bill
looked at finding ways uh to make it
easier to obtain the X waiver and have
some requirements around getting it so
that we could have more potentially more
practitioners serve more
patients
um our federal delegation members got
the X waiver removed federally
so what this then Tran then what I did
is I rewrote this to say okay the other
issue here
is that folks may or may not be getting
any substantive harm reduction education
in their medical programs
some of it's generationally
some of it just might be the the school
that you happen to go to
um and uh representative Nagel worked on
on this language as well but this seemed
to be an appropriate way saying when you
go up for re-licensing that you would
have gone online and uh taken up you
know this kind of standard three-hour
course this we do this with a lot of of
that continuing education
and um this will I think also address
some of the stigma issues there are some
practitioners and some practices who are
not you know what have some anxieties
about are we really going to be dealing
with this medical issue and I think that
the education will help with that so
that's why that's there
and then
um
uh
and finally
um get down to the the definitional side
that
um starts the middle of page six and uh
I as I said I think maybe best of
Representative Nagel comes up and talks
about how we got to this point with it
but it really gets to the heart of some
of the issues that representative
Edwards had and others that um if we're
going to be putting harm reduction and
recognizing it as a major
activity undertaking that the governor's
commission every and eight all the other
folks are doing and we're gonna you know
if we're undertaking that then the
legislature and if the legislature some
potentially you know might have to deal
with funding issues around it we ought
to have a definition that people feel
comfortable with
um and as you know from the last hearing
here there was great anxiety that this
somehow opened the door to Safe
injection sites
um I think actually this definition was
written to ensure that it did not but
um I this is an important issue that we
have to have some clarity on as I
mentioned the last time I was before you
I was the chair of our study committee
on harm reduction last summer and as a
result of that study committee we
explicitly said in our report that we do
not recommend say safe injection sites
that was an important you know our work
with the Mayors with the law enforcement
others that that was an important place
to land in that study
um so a harm reduction definition here
said here's what here's what you can do
and that was the approach that indicated
that it did not include that but if the
house would be more comfortable with an
explicit statement that nothing in this
definition shall include the
establishment of safe injection sites we
do that kind of thing
um but I I think it's awfully important
and this is why the build was retained
by Revenue Edwards to have there be
comfort with this I don't think there's
a whole lot of disagreement over the
other parts of the bill but
this is where we need the comfort so I I
you know representative Nagel I really
appreciate his work and you know and
then harking back you know resident
Solway uh um representative foreign reps
hand and it's always you know then
Karen no there's a lot of people caring
you know there's a lot of folks who can
can help you with this and I just soon
stop
Senator thank you so much and
considering um you know the
circumstances today are rather unique
but I appreciate it just very quickly
though before you go unless you have to
run uh just quickly so the lines you're
referring to specifically with regards
to Safe injection sites page six What
specifically lines
uh you said you said if we were to uh
amend it and place it in there where
where specifically
I would actually I think what you might
want to do and again representative
Nagel might be the best guy I don't know
this is just add another
um
another letter here in a year or
something that says nothing in this
definition shall include
um safe injection sites or something
like that so at the end of page six or
the top of page seven you say
somewhere there okay
yeah representative is that that might
if that's what's desired that might
um provide a nice uh closure of the
brackets because that section starts
this shall be limited to the following
and you could then end if it makes you
feel more comfortable with the second
bracket which is nothing is intended to
authorize yeah whatever you're not
intending to authorize and you can wrap
that up sorry if I may Madam chair you
could wrap that up real tight uh and say
that but also say and that nose funding
shall be you know no no funding shall be
provided for I mean you could you if if
that's important and I think it probably
it probably is you could wrap that up
real tight and you and you won't know
how to do that with legislative language
but uh I think that um it reflects the
sentiment of the report and I think it
reflects where the governor is is to
have that prohibition and it would be
useful I think in the language here real
good and then one more thing uh in
debriefing for today's session it was
brought up that uh Manchester and I'm
not familiar with the facts had a policy
issue or something to that effect with
regards to new needle exchange programs
there was a conflict in terms of a
policy that somebody had that conflicted
with the program do you know anything
about that or maybe others do and could
expand on that I can just speak briefly
because I had a lot of conversation with
mayor Craig and with the chief of police
and and others there and I will say
Manchester has is really
um the city of Manchester has has really
tried is trying very very hard through
its EMTs through the program it's even
offering to provide services surrounding
towns on harm reduction it's the
epicenter of a lot of our issues a lot a
lot of lives lost and so forth the
concern arose when the initiation of a
syringe exchange site was not done with
coordination
um with local officials I think
sufficiently and therefore where it was
set up how it was run
um created real real real real anxieties
and um and we heard a lot about it in
the study committee you can look at the
people who came to testify about it
um and I know that hope for New
Hampshire recovery and other groups have
since that time really kind of stepped
in to try to make sure that the program
has restored regained the trust and so
forth
um but it's it suggests to me that's why
it was important to include that
language about Constitution uh there are
there you know Portsmouth doesn't have a
program right there's some other cities
that don't have them and um if they're
going to set up a syringe exchange then
they ought the the you know I think we
can we can help by making sure that they
know
um that these programs at HHS you know
is authorizing are going to be done in
ways that they can feel comfortable with
locally so
that's that's a little more background
there but I'll just tell you more about
Manchester
real good since we're on that topic a
former representative Han and you had a
were you did you have something to add
to this particular issue before we move
to the next
okay you'll wait anyone else want to
contribute to the Manchester policy
conflict issue okay thank you very much
any other questions for Senator Waters
really appreciate your time thank you so
much I'm going to stick around very good
appreciate that
okay
any thoughts at this juncture from the
members all right
Mr Ripple at this point uh there was a
handout I know that representative
Edwards gave to you to give to us do we
have that already
I think you you should have it there are
actually two separate handouts as
everybody should have and if anybody on
that side doesn't have one or I might
have to make a few extra copies but um
okay excellent so we all have what we're
supposed to per chairman edwards's
request from Mr Ripple
okay
at this point I know we have some
members here who are interested in
talking uh however order you'd like to
go is fine with me but I know it was
asked representative Nagel I know you
have a lot of experience not only in
this bill but in other areas and perhaps
you could give your take and prior to
that if you could just go through your
credentials for the members of the
committee I think that would be very
helpful anywhere you'd like
let's see
it's like bagel with an n
thank you Mrs Madam chairman and if you
were chairwoman thank you and if just
shutting off that mic I think it might
lessen the perfect whenever you're ready
um thank you for this opportunity
um
yeah a couple minutes ago I was actually
taking care of the people we're talking
about right now so and I I really The
more I've talked with Senator Waters The
more I've been impressed with how
thorough
this process has been and how important
this issue is
um just I'm gonna go a little bass
backwards here if that's all right but
he addressed the issue of continuing
education requirements and and the
health care force and before I forget I
really wanted to throw out there that in
in the average medical school there is
virtually no education on addiction
there's
the average doctor will get seven hours
of treatment uh teaching in his entire
his or her entire medical education how
to manage pain
um that's an average some schools don't
do it at all
um I just personally funded a program at
the University of Rochester to make sure
that that
um issue was addressed so it's not
happening so um that's why this issue is
even more important as the health care
providers really aren't well educated on
these issues
so you want to know about me
um I'm a physician I practice in Concord
for over 30 years I was actually
recruited to New Hampshire I'm a
physical medicine and rehabilitation
specialist we deal with people with
complex disabilities
I was recruited here actually to work
with Easter Seals on the kinds of things
that you see on the ads and Easter Seals
and I also was recruited to start a
program and head injury which
unfortunately never happened
one of the things that I was never
taught really in education and that
became quite apparent is I started
managing these complex issues including
end of Life Care was how important pain
was part of all that
and I was struck with how little we were
taught how what we were taught was
inaccurate and how there had to be a
better way so the last 35 years of my
life has been a journey on trying to
learn
more on how to do that one of the things
I got from Medical School the University
of Rochester was to understand that the
doctor's office is not the patient's
home the patient's home is in the world
and that if I wanted to influence what
goes on in the world in their lives then
I needed to get involved with
policy advocacy things like that so for
the last 30 years I've been involved
first advocating for the rights of um
women that have lost a child we moved on
to post-concussive syndrome and then
later on pain I've been involved in
most of the legislation and Rule mate
writing in this state on on Pain Care
policy over the last 33 years I
initiated and wrote all the opioid
policies we updated them
recently I became struck that when we
have these beautiful models that you
handed out here that they always talk
about patient-centered care but we kind
of forget that the patients in the
center and that we neglect to listen to
them
so as a result of that I um I did three
things number one is um be out of anger
more than anything I wrote a book called
needless suffering which is a book on
Pain Care policy in the United States
it's actually sold worldwide and and
what started out as an angry catharsis
turned into a message that I was really
shocked how well this translated to
multiple groups
I also got involved with the NFL in
terms of creating Pain Care policy for
them thinking that naively perhaps that
if they could change the way we look at
head injury perhaps the way they could
change the way you look at pain and then
I started a couple of non-profits that
basically spoke for the patient so their
patient run patient directed and they
just happen to have a doctor stuck in
the middle of all that
um one of the things that bothered me a
lot was that I believe and I will
believe till the day I die that opioids
have a role in terms of managing pain
um and that denying patients access to
this can be dangerous and and a bad and
bad policy whether it's for chronic pain
acute pain end of life pain
um whatever we also understand that it's
not for everybody
um I think that we crafted legislation
very well to try to prevent what
happened with an opioid crisis we could
be very if you want we could talk for
hours about the Genesis of that crisis
but
I've always believed that for every
complex social problem there's a
solution that's neat simple and wrong
and I think the way we've addressed the
opioid crisis has been neat simple and
wrong and I think what we've ended up
doing is harming people that we're
benefiting from opioid therapy
um because of that
um I got I I started getting involved in
a number of legislative areas that I
felt that these people need to be stood
up for and that's functionally why I ran
for the office I wanted to get involved
in all these committees that I'm
creating I wanted to be on the opioid
abatement commission to make sure that
we directed those funds to where they
needed to go and not exclude a group
that we call opioid refugees
what opioid refugees are are patients
that were doing just fine and long-term
opioid therapy that now can't get access
to care and so frequently what they do
is one of three things they either
suffer needlessly they go to the streets
to buy their drugs which we call drug
misuse or they commit suicide and
unfortunately we do have a suicide watch
that we're keeping
um and we've counted over a thousand
suicides who are basically patients that
just don't have access to care and just
can't live with their pain anymore and
that's a bare minimum number we know the
number is substantially higher than that
so my motivation in getting involved in
this whole harm reduction thing and this
bill in particular and also Senate Bill
32 and the opioid abatement commission
which I'm the vice chair of
is is that I really felt that um
these this money that's pouring in
um for opioid abatement and for other
things really needed to address a
broader group of people
um we've for 30 years we've been
championing championing integrative care
and balanced public policy between the
people that suffer from paying the
people that suffer from the drugs that
we use from Pain and trying to achieve
this balance that we keep missing
that was my motivation so when this bill
came to us I was I was pretty excited at
first
um
primarily because if you look at the
statute that creates the opioid
abatement commission it has no there's
nothing in it that will pertain to my
people so for example if I'm on pain
medicine and my doctor suddenly out of
fear of DEA reprisal or on Medical Board
reprisal refuses to write opioid for me
anymore and I go to the street those
patients aren't included there's no
protection there's no harm reduction
measure for them and that was a problem
for me that I felt needed to be solved I
think Senate Bill 32 actually did solve
some of those issues but if you look at
that bill the term harm reduction is in
that bill but it is not defined when
these two bills came before our
committee the questions that we were
asking is what do you mean by harm
reduction what do you mean by substance
misuse why are you using these terms and
that became really important to me to
have those terms defined so number one
is that we're doing what we need to do
not doing what we shouldn't be doing and
including all the people that should be
included so like for example when we get
opioid abatement funds we have that term
harm reduction in the bill my people can
be included in that bill because I think
that that's important
um
the misuse issue is important to me for
a couple reasons
um
so
the word abuse is bait this is the way
we look at this in terms of addiction
and Pain Care policy
um abuse misuse is kind of a generic
term that includes multiple other things
so for example abuse is taking a
substance for a me uh for purpose other
than what's medically indicated so for
example if I take
um an opioid to get high you know that
that's that's not a medical indication
we don't prescribe opioids to make
people high
um diverting a drug to a source other
than what was intended that would be
considered abuse
um but there's also this other thing
that we know as epidemic in our
population and that's self-management
where patients are not getting the care
they need and that's another long
discussion we can have but they're not
getting the care that we need so they
just take it to themselves and they go
to the streets they go wherever to take
care of it the CDC guidelines on opioid
prescribing just documented last two
years ago that 70 percent of misuse in
this country is actually done for to
treat a medical symptom not to get high
not to get a manage an addiction but to
actually treat a problem that's not
being treated otherwise
um the reason why it was important to me
number one that we Define misuse but use
that term was that when you use the term
abuse you're not including those who are
self-medicating and I thought that those
people really needed to be included in
both of these bills
um and then that brings us to harm
reduction
um this was a very entertaining Journey
I've taken over the last couple of
months on this I've learned more in the
last couple months than I've learned
ever and in the end it's kind of like
you Circle back right to where you were
when you started I mean as a physiatrist
we treat people with complex
disabilities we have complex disability
models
and that involves a group of
professionals working together as a team
to help somebody achieve a goal
um that's functionally to me what harm
reduction is it's prevention with a
group of people working together
integrative fashion to try to achieve a
goal with using multiple modalities so a
prevention may be a single modality
whereas harm reduction is using multiple
modalities together so for example we
have a statute on syringe exchange
programs here they don't just exchange
needles they have to do all sorts of
other things they have to provide
infectious disease counseling they have
to provide drug counseling they need to
provide access to other services so
they're doing a lot of things together
and that in fact would be considered
harm reduction
however the word was not defined and so
I felt that it needed to be defined one
of the thoughts that I had that I think
is going to happen anyways that I think
should happen is that we sit down as a
group and figure out how that should be
defined the terms that we use on Page
Six in this the amended bill
that's taken directly from the samsa
website substance abuse mental health
Services Agency or Administration
we took that directly from there and
I've I've done some symposia nationally
with people from samhsa before I have a
lot of faith in them
um there's a lot of thought that went
into that definition and that's where we
took that from it's like verbatim from
their website
um I think that perhaps that it would be
a good idea after the discussion we just
had and that I've talked with
representative Edwards and others that
I think a further discussion and
clarification would be helpful
um
um but it's a start and and maybe not a
finish but I think it's important that
by January we have a finish
because this is really important not
just for people that suffer from
addiction disorders but also from people
in pain that are not getting the
treatment they need
and I think the only other thing I will
say is on the CME requirement that's in
this bill I think it's page five
um I I actually amended that and the
reason uh maybe it's page six
page five yeah
so the reason why we amended it is that
it already exists both in statute and um
in rules
um
but there is a new requirement that all
uh anybody that has a DEA license has to
have an eight-hour course on addiction
and pain
so that part is really
probably unnecessary
um I would leave that to others who are
more knowledgeable about legislative
processes than I am to decide that but
at this point I think that's unnecessary
um I think I'm done thank you
representative all very informative I do
have just one question to kick this off
um when you say pain are you talking
physical mental emotional or are there
other categories I'm missing could you I
guess break down the word pain for us so
um that is it absolutely a great
question so we just started a committee
on integrative care in New Hampshire and
we decided to spend our first two work
group sessions on defining pain the
International Association for the study
of pain brought together experts from
all over the world to answer that
question what we're taught I mean
we look at pain from a lot of different
perspectives
um nociception is a is like I pinch my
skin that sends a signal to my brain
that something hurts that's no
susception
what that means to me at the brain level
can be something very different like for
example I treated a patient years ago
that had a ruptured Achilles tendon
which hurts but it's very treatable
in his culture severing an Achilles
tendon
um was a punishment by God in his
religion and so he was devast it was his
faith and he was devastated by this
injury Way Beyond what you would expect
that's suffering to separate those two
every what we've understood for over 70
years is every symptom has has an
emotional element to it too so it's not
really a good idea to separate the two
so everything has a nociceptive element
every pain element has a suffering
element and it's important that we
recognize that and a spiritual element
um the other thing that I think that
we're focusing on is we also look at
pain from a time element so there's like
an acute pain like I pinched my arm here
I'm wearing sneakers because I got
plantar fasciitis and I got lucky enough
didn't have to run Mount Washington two
weeks ago which I was supposed to do
that's more of an acute pain nociceptive
thing I I hope otherwise I'm really
really suffering now because I didn't
get to do the race but anyway
um but that would be an acute pain
element we talk about perioperative care
post-operative care we talk about a
thing called acute pain chronically that
we use in talking with NFL players where
you're just constantly injuring yourself
over and over again but it's all
nociceptive and then we talk about
chronic pain which is pain that's kind
of a time element more that we Define
that as greater than three months but
that
that basically will include a central
component that's both suffering
emotional and peripheral we're not
including I'm a Buffalo Bills fan we've
had season tickets for 60 years the
suffering that I deal with and not
watching them when a Super Bowl every
year is not what we're talking about so
this opioid abatement money and the
governor's commission money would not
include me
um and then we talk about the term
serious pain which I really don't like
but that's the term that's used it's
like palliative care hospice care what
we're struggling with is do we include
them and what we're talking about here
and there's reasons to do it and there's
reasons not to do it but that that would
be another discussion if you want
very good thank you we're going to go
representative Weber for a question and
then representative Shapiro
thank you madam chairman was very narrow
and it went back to the bottom of page
five with the uh licensing requirement
uh you said that perhaps not needed
because now eight hours on pain
management is is required
um is it helpful or not helpful to have
the specific requirement of three hours
of harm reduction
that's included in that because they're
they're one is a subset of the other but
could be left out
um because we don't really have any
statute that addresses education and
addiction that I'm aware of
um it may be a good idea to do that
and refer to addiction medicine harm
reduction whatever the way the statutes
um written now it could be either or but
the eight hour requirement does include
addiction I I don't really know the
details of what they're requiring that
you teach I don't I don't think harm
reduction by itself is in that okay
clarification
thank you representative Nagel I might
have
misunderstood something here so please
indulge me
I know that um this has been incredibly
controversial we've voted on
I don't know two three four iterations
of a definition of harm reduction
already and we're still not there
somehow so we're trying to make it
as narrow and tight as possible
to make it less controversial to
actually
um have broader consensus and acceptance
but I heard you talk about
opioid refugees and people who ended up
essentially purchasing
illegal medications or medications that
are legal but purchasing them on the
street because they can't get them and I
thought I heard you say that these this
activity should be included in in the
definition of harm reduction as well
and I'm wondering if that's the case
number one how that would be worded and
number two how that would ever pass
muster and get consensus to be passed as
a part of a bill like this you know what
I found really fascinating is that when
I brought that issue up the people that
were opposed to this bill started
thinking this bill was a good idea
and um
um you know
66 million people have chronic pain in
the United States
um about 50 25 million people
have um what we call high impact chronic
pain meaning that their quality of life
is significantly deteriorated because of
their pain
um fewer than two million people have
opioid use disorder and and about 10 of
the population has a substance use
disorder of some sort so we're talking
about numbers that are a lot bigger than
other numbers are
and and the money that we've taken
from from Pain we've taken to substance
use and we've kind of
trying to think of a plate were to use
but I just don't think it's really
appropriate to adversely affect one
group to help another group
so that's why I think that that is what
policy has done and that's why what I
think we need to do is shift us back to
the middle and we really need to find
that middle ground so to answer your
question
um just a representative Edwards and I
had this discussion and and he's of the
belief that that a provision of some
sort should be added to the definition
of harm reduction but it glossary as you
suggested earlier but we use a separate
term for that group of people and not
call it harm reduction
he he I can't remember the term he used
I I didn't like it but um
um I think we can do better but but his
point was good and his point was the
same as yours yep to follow up I just
think that to add that into the
definition of harm reduction would make
this to a lot of people seem more Broad
and more controversial and more
difficult to actually get achieve
consensus to get the bill passed and I
really like your idea of a glossary
because we've done that with every Bill
I've ever written we had a glossary of
all these terms in there and um and I do
like the idea of what I'm proposing be
in this bill but as a separate entity do
you think that would help
I I guess I would I would have to
see what language was used and what it
was you know how how it was incorporated
I certainly think it would I'm not
saying I disagree with you in any way
I'm just thinking that if it was
included in this definition of harm
reduction
um it would just
um
make it more controversial rather than
less controversial
um so I would you know if you have ideas
about language that would put it into a
different section of the bill
um
or if I could work on that with you I'd
be glad to do that I think that will
require some work and I'd be yeah this
issue just came up like two days ago and
I thought at first I was kind of opposed
to it because I do think that it is harm
reduction
but um I've talked to people to muddy
the waters a lot I've talked to people
from all over the country about this
concept and there's like varying ideas
of what the topic even means and um
um I think you know the things that were
handed out to us today were a great
overview of and I think that's a general
consensus but you know when I talk to
some people that's not it at all and
other people yeah it's definitely it
representative Shapiro for a follow-up
and then representative Weber yep I
would just like to say you know as I
mentioned before there have been many
iterations of this language that have
been discussed in our committee in
health and human services and um and
been voted on and been voted on in front
of the house and I voted for all of them
um because
um in my mind
no matter how we no matter how tight we
make the definition of harm reduction
number one we can't um predict what's
going to come in the future so we can't
it I don't understand how we can
legislate a Prohibition prohibition of
things we don't even know about yet and
also I think there are many many other
guard rails besides this definition
which will determine whether other
activities are
promoted allowed licensed in the future
you have to get funding for things you'd
have to get approval you'd have to get
them through regulations the legislature
could act on those new ideas when they
came up so I think there are other guard
rails aside from just this definition of
harm reduction
I don't I don't disagree and I I we've
this has prompted a lot of discussion
and one of the members of the governor's
commission and I hope she and I've been
friends and dealt done this policy work
for a long time she said that it's
almost a non-definable term it's a
concept
and trying to define something that's
non-definable will always create
problems
um so I I do think that putting Minds
together to really think this throughout
has a lot of value and we did suggest
that I think as you recall in our
committee right from the very beginning
that it was suggested that we actually
do what we looks like we're gonna end up
doing anyways
I just wanted to explore a little bit
one of the one of the joys of serving on
Health and Human Services this year has
been access to you and your knowledge of
uh program of problems that
I have seen small pieces of in my life
um as as somebody who who had a a spouse
die of cancer and all the pain
management issues that come with that uh
and then as an issue of public policy
and one of the things that I love is
exploring the global
view that you're talking about here
because one of the frustrations of
uh passing legislation that I have is
that we do tend to
look at small bites
um
that having been said I do think that
one of the things that the committee as
it deliberates further needs to do is to
decide whether a bill that started out
as looking at a specific program
for one specific issue and therefore had
a specific definition
[Music]
tailored for that particular purpose
is the appropriate vehicle for a global
view of how we ought to be dealing with
an issue that we certainly are not
looking at
enough in a global fashion so I I just
uh bringing the attorney mind to it
this actually is One Piece
of a much larger puzzle and I'm not sure
that trying to come up with a definition
that encompasses
all of the different kinds
of situations that don't relate to this
program is is necessarily going to be a
useful way of dealing with it and I just
I just wanted to highlight that tension
and
um
welcome welcome your comments on it but
I'm I'm concerned that we're trying
possibly to
in trying to be inclusive we're
including things that don't actually
um
belong in this statute because this
statute was intended to be much narrower
so any any comments you yeah
this is why this whole thing was really
important to me
um 330 million dollars in opioid
abatement money I have a series of
programs that we would like to create
that would help number one help people
avoid
um people in pain avoid being on
long-term opioid therapy but you know
integrative care things like that the
things that nobody in this country is
doing well
and and then secondly how do we deal
with patients that once they're on
opioid therapy
um how do we help them if they've if
they've been abandoned how do we help
them
I want them to have access to that 330
million dollars
that's why it was important to me that
they get included in this legislation
because that is what this legislation is
about it's about the governor's
commission and the opioid abatement
commission I share your concerned
because the definition I believe is
going to go in the control Drug Act if
I'm not mistaken and then all of a
sudden you've taken a definition that's
going to go
you know viral to use a
colloquial term that that concerned me
you know misuse I think should be in the
controlled Drug Act I I'm not sure if
harm reduction should be
um I think that is more germane to this
that help
thank you Senator Waters you wanna
comment on that yes
thank you madam chair
um
and I just this is as much for Dave or
representative Nagel um it seemed to me
on Page Six
line 13 and 14. that the definition that
you developed here
that this is an important line drug
misuse refers to the substance
here's a substance for a purpose that's
not consistent with legal or medical
guidelines and I I think that's awfully
important because it does recognize what
has been said about
we need we need to be able to prescribe
to folks
um and I think that's important there
but I think the bifurcation in the bill
is that that that's a good placeholder
for things you're talking about and I do
think the governor's commission you know
has actually some programs right now
that are funded about education on on on
on on you know what the consequences for
folks who are using opioids for pain
reduction and then problems develop oh
good this the student High School the
highest the student athlete program we
fund all through our schools is exactly
on that so I think I think that's an
important thing I think actually it
really is a placeholder for you there
I think that it's important because of
the question of Representative Shapiro
raised that we're not that harm
reduction is not going to mean that
somebody who can't get a Percocet
um
subscription anymore from their doctor
can go to a syringe exchange site and
get percocet no you know harm reduction
are the things here and I think you
agree with that but I I just I think
that's why because of the question that
came up that I think the clarity here
and what representative Weber was saying
too is that we have a lot more to do
about opioids about prescription about
all these other things but about harm
reduction
we know we can save some lives if we
recognize and and do what we need
legislatively around the programs that
we're we're working on so I didn't mean
to interrupt but I just think that that
was a Clarity that you actually had put
something in here that really your your
primary concern there and read his book
you know it's a good book um but uh
title written down you know but that's
why I want to point that out Madam chair
and thank you
that was perfect no that was awesome and
I think you you also raised that same
issue that maybe we should be defining
this separately you know and I think
that's perfect for this bill what you
have in there is is good thanks
thank you both thanks for the plug
anything further for uh representative
Nagel all right thank you very much for
uh being here and letting your knowledge
on this
with us also today uh representative
soloway representative Hannon if you
would both um like to say some words or
comments on this bill now would be the
time
uh thank you madam chair
um for the record
um I am Jeffrey salloway a former
representative from the town of Lee
um and uh sat on a committee on Health
and Human Services uh LED at various
times by representative Weber and I'm
going to speak uh briefly
um to uh uh s wage uh representative
Nagel's feelings about medical education
I am the author of uh two volume set
when I was teaching in medical schools
one of which was epidemiology of drug
and alcohol abuse and the second was
epidemiology of treatment of drug and
alcohol abuse those are available on
Amazon under the antiquarian no
collectible value section
um I I want just to speak briefly to the
bill I am basically in favor of the bill
however I want to speak about paradigm
shift this bill is I think the first
step in a paradigm shift in the way that
we deal with substance misuse I do not
believe that it goes nearly far enough I
believe completely with representative
Weber that there is much more to be done
there are major pieces that are missing
you are aware that we do not attend to
alcohol
misuse and
70 percent of the substance misuse in
this country is based in alcohol uh one
in 10 Americans are alcoholic and we
simply move on without attending to that
in this bill
so it's necessary that we take a look at
the whole issue of substance misuse and
change our paradigms some of you may be
familiar with the work of the historian
Barbara touchman she wrote a book called
the march of folly and in that book she
talks about campaigns social military
political that have been launched
through history when the perpetrators of
those campaigns knew full well that they
risked abject failure and forged ahead
anyway into abject failure we sent a
copy of that to Vladimir Putin I don't
believe that he read the book
um we need to take a look at the work of
Edwin sure
s-c-h-e-r uh who wrote on drug abuse in
Britain and America
that book was published over 50 years
ago in which he said if America is to
deal with substance misuse problems it
has to decriminalize the use of those
substances in the way that the British
have decriminalized decriminalized it
one of the things that we do not do is
to destroy the market for illicit
substances by making them available
under prescription and with supervision
um
it's necessary to change our entire
approach to decriminalize to understand
that in the words of our Stratford
County sheriff and our Stratford County
attorney you cannot deal with this
problem by arresting it out of existence
we have to change the Paradigm I'm
privileged today to have uh to my right
representative a former representative
Joe Hannon I must say it is to my far
right that uh representative Heenan is
here
um and he has much more experience than
I do with um
boots on the ground in Stratford County
he has a long history of identifying
ways to deal creatively with substance
misuse and with your kind permission
Madam chair I'd like to turn it over to
him for his wisdom
excellent thank you welcome former
representative Hannan
okay thank you
um
so as you heard from the senator earlier
I was involved in the syringe exchange
legislation for the programs uh I was
also the chair of the commission to
study New Hampshire syringes
um
and um
I was a founding member of the harm
reduction group that started a lot of
this original syringe service programs
and up until about four months ago I was
actively involved in uh going out and
actually doing the work on the streets
and the side of the road and wherever we
were doing the syringe work I'll just
fill you in a couple I'll answer some of
the questions that were brought up
earlier uh the xylazine test strips they
do exist uh they're a little more
expensive than the fentanyl test strips
but it's I'm sure the price will come
down as it become more
used uh they're about I saw the the
quickest one the most recent one I saw
is about two dollars and fifty some
cents per test strip fentanyl test
strips are about a dollar or less I
believe but that depends on bulk buying
um
another thing uh is the uh the use of uh
the definition of harm reduction
services and this is something that I've
actually wrestled with with people in
the organization that I used to be a
part of what is harm reductions um what
is harm reduction in the beginning uh it
was just syringe Services that's all we
did we just wanted to get the syringes
out there naloxone Narcan was a big part
of that but obviously there's a lot more
to it there's no one definition if you
look around uh different parts of the
country uh in different certain service
programs or harm reduction groups there
are basic principles that they all
generally agree to
um and one is that uh and they're in the
packet that was handed out I believe uh
harm reduction practices and evidence
and educational resource for New
Hampshire decision makers I wasn't a
part of this
uh publication but I was a part of some
of the
um parts of it before it was formed
um
a number one of the biggest things is it
accepts the drugs use accepts drug use
is part of our world and chooses to work
to minimize its harmful effects rather
than simply ignore or condemn them so
harm reduction is not promoting drug use
it's not trying to say you know hear
some drugs you know good luck it's
better that I'm giving you this that
might be a part of something in a safe
injection facility which by the way have
not had a single overdose death in a
facility worldwide ever they've given
millions of uh people have gone it
millions of people have used in those
programs not people but millions of
times and no one has actually died
because someone's there to take care of
them some countries actually do
Supply the substances but generally you
bring your own you can use test strips
there's a sterile or clean area to use
instead of having to use in a uh in a
porta potty or in some alley somewhere
people
um are less likely to get infections
die it's a very good option it's
something that the opioid the governor's
task for the commission was looking at
peripherally when I was on it years ago
and it's not a New Concept that they've
been looking at the research is still
ongoing and because there aren't that
many of them around there's one in New
York there's a lot of legal issues with
it also because there's a federal
prohibition on having it in a facility
um so I don't know if banning that
concept is actually going to matter
because it's not going to happen until
it gets passed into law anyway
so either way I think it's a you know
extraneous Point uh if something that
people are worried about I understand
when the syringe service legislation was
passed there was a Senator I'm not going
to name names but who voted for it who
said you know as long as they don't
start uh you know putting uh safe
injection places out there and I was
like well just be quiet you know it's
probably going to happen eventually but
I I don't know when that's going to
happen I'm not a part of an effort right
now to do that although I think it's a
good idea to look into and uh to study
people aren't dying when they are
they're in a safe environment and
someone can help revive them
um xylazine test strips it's also
something very no um it's a common sense
thing the one thing that was brought up
about uh
paraphernalia was
um you know pipes and Cottons and I can
answer any questions about specific
items like if you're wondering were
Cottons or use four cotton balls or
tourniquets they're they're used to
Cotton their preparation equipment it's
things that people use to prepare the
heroin or fentanyl usually now
um or any other injectable drug to
inject it more safely uh previous uh
historically people and still people do
this they would use cigarette butt
filters and because you have to actually
draw the syringe through a spoon or a
cooker of some kind after they heat it
up and kind of purifies it to a degree
but it helps get rid of the bigger
chunks that might be in there so you're
not injecting something into a vein and
causing an infection or death so it is
something that is is is is it's actually
as important or more important than when
you go get a flu shot and they swab your
arm with alcohol you're creating uh one
thing that lessens the harm for sticking
a needle in the human body so cotton
balls tourniquets they help the veins
during the injection process cookers
little uh they're not we don't give out
spoon bent spoons but they would have
little teacup little things that have
little handles and people can safely
cook and dispose of things without
sharing the same cooker over and over I
talked to several people who have are
currently in recovery who had previously
used who got hepatitis from sharing
cookers they said I'm using clean
needles I don't know how I got hepatitis
well they all took a clean needle and
kept putting it into the same they all
had their own needles but they were
putting into the same cookers so they're
an integral part of preventing HIV
hepatitis and the spread of other
infectious diseases and just general
well-being like I said nobody is
condoning and saying it's a good idea to
do any drugs whatsoever drugs have their
purpose
um like the doctor was saying you know
opioids have a role and I think it's
important to to realize that heroin had
a role medically at one point many of
the drugs on this schedule one list
actually do have medical uses they're
just vilified and not legal in the at
the federal level so you know that is
changing I think over time I I don't
know if it's going to happen in New
Hampshire until it happens at the
federal level but I think it's important
to realize that the preparation
equipment and pipes and things like that
are very necessary to prevent infections
and other things now the actual law says
um you know attempt to be a part of a
comprehensive service program that may
include as appropriate providing sterile
needles syringes and Other Drug
preparation equipment and Disposal
Services so drug preparation equipment
is kind of peripherally included in
what's allowed now one thing that people
and I see this often and many people in
volunteers and people even working for
syringe service programs is in New
Hampshire they think that you know you
can't get arrested if you're a part of a
syringe service program it's actually
not true the way the original law was
written and still is I believe correct
me if anyone knows differently it's it
went from a felony to have a residual
amount of uh illicit substance in a
syringe or around it a non-usable amount
is what we're trying to find but a trace
amount and that used to be a felony so
seven years in jail we made it a
misdemeanor so if you have an unusable
amount of drugs in a syringe it's a
misdemeanor and if you are a part of a
volunteer worker or a participant of a
syringe service program that's licensed
that's recognized by New Hampshire you
have an affirmative defense if you get
arrested for that possession so
technically every time I was out there
they could have arrested me I wish they
would because that would be a great PR
stunt but um you know it never happened
I tried
um you know most often the police know
what's going on and they they don't
interfere they may not like it but the
biggest thing is that because it was
made a misdemeanor no prosecutor is
going to waste their time just
Prosecuting a possession charge when
they could go after them for fentanyl
possession or deal or you know
distribution all kinds of other charges
so the idea was to to destigmatize those
those items uh and it's hard because I
rely is that Law Enforcement wants to
use them as pieces of evidence or as
probable cause to make an arrest for
something else I understand that's a
part of it but it's you know if you see
a diabetic in a car sticking a needle in
their belly or in their arm you know
it's not pro it's not cause to arrest
that person
but you'd want it almost seems like they
they want something to arrest them for
and I think that's a dangerous road to
go down I think they should all be
um allowed as far as preparation and
safe uh you know if whether you're
legalizing the substance or not it's a
different discussion but as far as the
things that prevent illness infection
and make the use which is probably
happening anyway whether we like it or
not to make it safer and less harmful I
think is very important and I don't want
to go on forever because I could but
I'll just to say one or two real quick
things and I'll answer any questions
um another there's principles of harm
reduction that are listed here I won't
go all through all of them but one of
them says you know ensures that pwid PW
UD people who use drugs have a real
voice in the creation of programs and
policies designed to serve them
um so I I know that the commission is
supposed to have I think uh I can't
remember two num two members from the
harm reduction Community or one from
prevention one from harm reduction uh it
says professionals a lot of times there
were volunteers and now it's a lot less
volunteers than it used to be we had a
it was predominantly all volunteer run
for a long time and they've seemed to
have done away with that over time
um very educated there were doctors
nurses paramedics who are these
volunteers uh now there's some very
qualified and experienced people who are
gaining experience but uh you know
the idea is to have someone who is
involved in the community and can and it
affects them more directly than just
someone who's volunteering or working
for them so people who use drugs and
this is something that was talked about
in one of the opioid tasks for I was on
the opioid task force years ago and it
was talked about getting someone
involved who's actively using drugs to
be involved in making policies I realize
that's a difficult thing to do because
sometimes they may or may not show up
and I know it's a stereotype but it
became a it's a reality sometimes we've
tried to get people to show up but I
think it's important to include people
who whether they're actively using or or
in recovery at the very least should be
involved in the process and I think that
should be something that could easily be
um be added
um last thing
um
uh as far as the definition I think it's
it's going to be really hard to make a
definition but I think it's important to
to keep the focus
um to actually have a focus I mean
prevention is a big amorphous term we
don't definition we don't really Define
specifics of prevention
um and and even recovery it's evolving
it's an evolving field but I do think
that uh harm reduction is something that
from my experience uh the definition can
be whatever you want it to be and so can
recovery in in some senses I was part of
a recovery organization and we said you
know you're in recovery when you say you
are and if you're getting a bunch of
doctors to say what is recovery and to
come up with the definition it's very
hard to do when people are saying you're
in recovery when you say you are you
know whether someone is using regularly
or someone is completely abstinent it's
a Continuum and I think it's important
to recognize that people live on that
Continuum sometimes and they may be in
recovery someone who is using 10 bags of
heroin a day is a very serious chronic
user probably but they may be functional
not judging it but I'm the goal for harm
reduction wouldn't be to say oh we're
going to get them to stop it the first
goal is to say we're going to help them
do it safely and not get sick and die
because if they're sick even if they get
in recovery what's the point if they're
going to die
so we want to get people to the next
level we're not pushing people we don't
coerce them we don't try to make them
quit or do things the way we want them
to we give them what they need and then
we show them Alternatives so pipes is
something that made the news everyone's
so upset about these crack pipes and
smoking pipes out there it's an
alternative to actually sticking a
needle in your arm for many people so if
the choice is do I stick a needle in my
arm or smoke something you know yes it's
smoke might not be as good for the lungs
but you're much less likely to catch a
bloodborne infection almost you know
drastically less so there are things
that have to be considered but I do
think that you can't say harm reduction
is or recovery is anything I say it is
and then have that be part of policy so
I think as far as the harm reduction of
recovery world I think it's fine to have
those amorphous definitions because it
is evolving and people do relate
differently and have different ideas but
I think if you're going to have a policy
where there's going to be money involved
and there's different political side
someone on the far right of this former
representative and someone to my you
know far left here
um you you have to be able to to make
that Focus somehow I'm not sure how to
do that and I'm I'm not here to give you
all the answers I'm just here to you
know give some background and maybe help
with the solution but um I think that's
um
I've talked enough I'd be happy to
answer any questions if anyone has any
um specifics about harm reduction or
about uh safe injecting or anything
and if not I'll be quiet you can go to
lunch thank you we do have one
representative Weber for question
I just had drafting question
specifically
um you were talking about uh including
the perspective of a person who has used
drugs and uh with the term lived
experience be appropriate for that yes
absolutely okay that might be easier and
also
um then you're not defining sorry then
you're not defining whether they're
still actively using because someone
might know well it's it's much broader
but it does uh recognize that
none of us who have not been in that
position
uh have the perspective
that somebody who has what
excellent thank you anyone else
all right appreciate that anyone in the
audience wishing to address this work
session at this point
okay
oh you have a question
looking for
sure come right up looks like the mic's
already on for you there at the table
I think what you brought up was really
important
um but there's a way I this may be a
sidebar conversation but like um having
a patient or a a client or a customer
whatever you call them um involved in
the process is critical and we've done
that with everything we've done but you
vet who they are and you can and you can
get them but how we put that in
legislation is really important but I
think in everything we do if we're going
to call it patient-centered you really
have to include
a patient two three four yeah
real good
um again anything further from the
committee at this point okay oh
representative Shapiro
I I would just like to say that you know
speaking about the specific Bill versus
the broader societal and policy issues
um it's the whole issue of stigma and um
I think we've frequently talk about
stigma in you know in the mental health
field and in addictions and we want to
reduce stigma because we want people to
um
get treatment or use harm reduction
methods
but for me personally this is the
question of whether we want to do away
with stigma completely or to or the
taboo about using alcohol and and
um
drugs because
if we do away with it are we in some way
making it
making it the norm and encouraging
people to do something that um
is generally harmful for their lives and
for the for society in general so I I
think that's kind of a big philosophical
question but I think it's in some ways
it's part of the subtext here because
when we talk about harm reduction I
think
some people immediately jump to what
we're going to keep people healthier and
safer and um prevent deaths and then
other people jump to are we making this
kind of a normal activity and in that
way encouraging people and so I think
that's an important balance that we need
to strike in all these bills
representative Weber
and just as a follow-up to that I I have
been having a certain amount of angst
over a suggestion I made earlier which
was
um
putting using his brackets the the end
point of nothing she'll create a a safe
injection site and I will I'm now
thinking because I reread the end of the
bill as it stands now
I'm I'm thinking that that might better
go up where we already have the limited
to language because I love the fact that
this bill ends currently with promote a
philosophy of Hope and healing by
utilizing those with lived experience of
recovery in the management of harm
reduction services and connect those who
expressed interest to treatment peer
support workers and other recovery
Support Services I love the idea of
ending on a note of Hope
and I realized that that may be
incompatible with good legal drafting
but it's still it's a nice note
okay uh thank you all for being here
this was very informative and your
knowledge is certainly appreciated I
know how much time it takes to watch a
bill go through the process and uh
contribute and answer questions and
present possibly even
um duplicatively from what you've said
previous at other hearings so we really
appreciate that I'm going to close this
work session on Senate Bill 239 it will
likely be rescheduled for September for
another work session at that point and
that's where we stand thank you all
again
foreign